you know you don't care you don't come
back
short if you come back with it all
or you get your ass worked and i mean
whooped
you know and you got to go right back
out there you don't care
it doesn't matter to him because he sit
back like a pill
so wait why we out there laying on the
back sucking that you know what i'm
saying i'm getting [ __ ] all the
whatever you know
when i was 17 i had been put in the
trunk
um i was walking down the street i was
on el segundo
maine and i got on broadway
and i checked the court and i seen a car
and
he pulled over he looked like a nice guy
you know he was clean-cut
and tie and you know dressed nice and
asked me to get in and i did you know
even took me
you know out to eat and went to a bar
everything then when i told him you know
okay i'm ready to go home you know we
can keep in touch with whatever
he turned the other way and i'm like
where are we going
and don't worry about it you know what
i'm saying and
we ended up in a factory
and i seen these knives on the side of
this
you know on this side it was not like
one it was two or three of them you know
what i'm saying
and um i had that kind of nervous and he
locked the door
and i'm i'm like what are you locking
the door for
he said don't worry about it [ __ ] and
what you know
all the time i'm thinking you know i'm
i'm gonna die you're gonna kill me
but i had time enough to get out because
he was always
he was reaching this way because he
asked me to take off my clothes and as i
was like
playing like i was going to take them
off i was trying to
unlock the door but he was still on the
side
you know getting the knives and luckily
i just
unlocked it and got out but he snatched
me
and i pulled from him and i ran and he
was running after me he was running
after me with the knife and luckily when
i came
out the uh alleyway
there was three men that was working at
the factory it was outside and i was
hollering and they really didn't pay too
much attention
as me running down the street but he had
stopped when he seen them and turned
back around
and one got in his car and left so i had
just ran just kept
running you know i had my shoes in my
hand everything i kept running but i
never told anyone this you know
and um after that it was just
it was a bad experience and then another
time
[Music]
i was on pig [ __ ] roar
nice looking you know whatever you know
dumb don't try it again and i did and
we talked or whatever i always start
good but then it don't
he took me to his house oh yeah took me
to his house with a nice home
sat drink whatever and
he said you know and then he was like do
you like kinky stuff and i'm like well
it's not really but okay you know
i'll try it you know so
tied me to the bed i'm like okay
she's not gonna try my ankles and he's
like no but
after a while i was feeling kind of
drowsy
you know like if he put something in the
drink which he did and i just like
passed out
and next thing i woke up i was on the
sidewalk by the bus stop
because i had passed out on a drink so
after uh you know
everything was over
you know he had set me on a bus stop and
then i had
woke up because when i woke up i was
laying on the bus stop on the bench and
i
woke up and i don't know what drug he
gave me or whatever but
i was still kind of you know drowsy from
the drug
and i found my way
home you know staggering and whatever
and it's just you know it's been wrong
and then my finger right here
that i got broke
it was from another time
i was in the park
and it was somebody i knew
somebody i knew
and we were there drinking you know on
the bench
and he asked me to do something i told
him no
took my arm turned it around he said
[ __ ] i'll break your finger
and i kept telling him no and i was
trying to you know get away but i
couldn't
he was big
and he broke it he broke my finger
yeah and
i had just i don't know
and i knew him i knew him but
the ones you know don't always be the
ones you think you know
you know but
your your experience that first time was
hey this is easy money
i needed money oh that's not gonna
happen again
but it did well i'm gonna try this one
more time
but it did and but this was someone i
knew
i broke my finger you know
and then another time
it's just been bad what is it about this
lifestyle that
attracts so many women um
you don't need the education you don't
need the education you don't need
anything other than no
money the looks the body
the you know the attitude
everything the strut just everything you
know the
clothes and it's just an easy way to
make it faster
the gap you know all that
you know what i'm saying all they want
is they money you know
i wanted to try it because
this person i knew he he wanted to like
okay
i'll be with you you know but i had
second thoughts and i was like no
because i know how they are you know
and plus the experience i've been
through
who needs a pimp you know what i mean
if i get a pimp he gonna do the same
thing if i don't bring all the money you
know
um this other man
i was down i was in englewood
i walk in seen each other talk
now he took what he wanted for me
and then bust my mouth without my teeth
i got no key
took you know didn't give me nothing
just
took what he wanted
i don't know he was some kind of
i don't know crazy you know
but a lot of girls get they seem to get
addicted to this life
i was at the time i was i was young i
was naive you know what i'm saying
you know this won't be better than it
was you know then it's going to be
better than what's in you know i'm
thinking it you know
i come along to a person that's with me
but then i was
looking in the wrong places even though
the lifestyle i was living you know what
wrong place could you look i mean
where you go it's going to be wrong
somewhere but all the time it was wrong
looking back at how many years did you
do it are you still doing
um i kind of slowed down i'm slow down
but it's been since i was 17
i stopped when i was like i don't know
34 you know um
but looking back at your career did you
save money
was it a good well really not
no i really didn't i had bought clothes
for drugs you know what i'm saying
cigarettes whatever i needed you know uh
it's just a way to survive
yeah that's all i was doing is survivor
so when i get the money i get what i
needed what i wanted what i've seen and
didn't have money and get it
you know what i'm saying that i have a
lot of a lot of the girls and a lot of
the pims tell me that they were making a
thousand
dollars a lot of plus you know what i'm
saying
i'll put wait but how much were you
making tonight
um i don't know um three four
dollars that was nothing do you think
that's a more realistic number than the
numbers i get
very often uh no do you think
girls make more yes very much so
um the whole point is when you
working for someone you don't what you
get you get nothing
you know what i mean when you out there
in the streets laying on your back all
night
shoes on your hands and walking the
streets all night tired
what you do you got to come and give it
to him you know what i'm saying
then you got to get back out there if
it's not enough if it's not what he
wants you know what i mean
and then if it's not what he wants and
he see it he's going to beat your ass
you don't care he just want his money
you know he that's all he wants
yeah he may feed you clothes you get you
high
whatever but you got to get back out
there until you have his money
you know you don't care you don't come
back short
if you come back with it all or you get
your ass worked
and i mean whooped you know and you got
to go right back out there
you don't care it doesn't matter to him
because he sit
back like a pill so wait why are we out
there laying on her back sucking that
you know what i'm saying i'm getting
[ __ ] all the
whatever you know whatever it takes to
get this man money
but what what what is it that gets so
women like brainwashed into doing this
because it doesn't seem to make sense
it's not convincing
[Music]
you know hey you know i like you you
know the confession
as you get convinced then
and you go by what he's saying and you
like what he's saying to you you know
the words he said you take him and he oh
he liked me you know what i'm saying
he want me to move with him but all the
time he wants you
to do others for him but this is how he
gets you in
you know what i'm saying you can come
live with me you know i like you
you know what i'm saying i'll do
everything for you but as he strayed you
in with them words
and you go for it it's others have you
ever you know have you ever thought you
know making money or whatever well how
you know make a little money for me you
know okay
all right which i know
it's wrong but it's not wrong because i
like this man you know i'm saying he
likes me
you know i mean so i'm gonna do whatever
he want me to do for him you know what
i'm saying to make him happy
and it goes to that
you know and it's it's it's sad
when i know i should have been doing
other things with my life
but i i choose to do that
because of the money you know what i'm
saying i've talked to a few hundred
of that was fine i was fine with it yeah
i talked to a couple hundred like two or
three hundred girls that have done this
and not not a single one has come back
and said yeah
he gave me a lot of money at the end but
you know he looked out he dressed
whatever but
he gave me 100 200 for me
but i had one thing i had to get back
out there
you know regardless of what he gave me i
still had to go lay on my back
suck dicks [ __ ] ass everything
or i get last week you understand i
couldn't come
short i couldn't say okay big daddy um i
only made a thousand
when i'm supposed to make two uh get
slapped
you know just get my ass feet and get
back out there
so i wouldn't come back until i had it
if it took me two or three days
half of the night half the morning i
wouldn't come back because i know when i
come and ain't gonna be nothing nice
so when i do come back with the money
it's just here and that's it
there's no way to get out um
no not really no i mean you can
but you have to look behind you all the
time
you can't work you can't work i'm the
one that's making the money you can't
work the street anymore
uh no i can't be seen really because
he has people out there you know if
you're seeing you see that [ __ ]
you get her and bring it to me i don't
know what's going on he can kill me
beat my ass some more have him beat me
have him kill me i don't know
so it's really no way up
there's really no way up and the only
way i got out
he died that's how i got out
i fell down and died of cancer that's
how i got out
other than that i'd probably still be in
the game
still being right now he was still here
because you know the pimps don't play
the pimps is with it
you know what i'm saying they don't give
a [ __ ] how old
what you got to do because they ain't
got to you just get
out there and get my money and come on
back and get it
you know and that's it that's all if you
don't you get to ask it
you know you do it i'll be nice uh to
make you happy
you know what i mean if he don't got
what he wanted
you ain't get nothing you know
probably get a piece of bread probably
get a dollar or two
maybe more but you know he won his money
and that's what it's about i just seen
him
tie this girl up this hole in the chair
because she came back with nothing
nothing well i couldn't make it
it was slow i couldn't get no clients
told this little boy to tear up put a
sheet over her
and whooped her with a baseball bat
and told her to get back out there and
get his money
so that
you know happened to me that's why
it's hard to get out it's hard
but why would you not come back with his
money knowing
doing the type of thing for you to do if
it's not tying you up beating your ass
with a bat he gonna beat your ass with
his hands
you know but you come back with nothing
come on
even if you came back with half of it he
still beat your ass because that's not
what he wanted he wanted all this money
but
they tied her up put a sheet over and
took it back and
beat her ass and then he told her to go
back on the streets
and get his money and she did
it's hard
it's hard because you're going to get
bound if you try to get out of it if you
try to run away
if you try to just not be with it no
more
you're going to get found and it's not
going to be a pretty thing and the young
girls don't figure this out
you know every you know they know i know
you know right from wrong you know this
is not right anyway in your life you
know what i'm saying but
somehow that's the choice you made
you think it's glamorous you think it's
cool but it's really not because as you
live
in it and go about it you'll soon find
out
i'm getting my ass what i gotta lay on
my back every night
i can't come home without this money and
all this money
if i don't i'll be sitting in the chair
tied up with a sheep getting beat
or him beating me then the consequences
you know thing
so why ask why
you know that's that's how
the life is and like i said look
you know i was lucky because he had died
from cancer which he was sick then but
not
sick sick but he was you know
losing starting to lose weight you know
starting not to be how he was you know
slower at things but and that wasn't the
first one
he had another uh another prostitute
but i didn't see that he told them to
take her in the room and tie her to the
bed
all i heard was her holler what they did
i don't know
she comes out and she had to go back out
on the street because she only gave half
of the money
he don't want that he want all of it if
you don't get all of his money why the
[ __ ] you come back
this man is not playing you know he got
people that's going to come out there
and seek
and find you no matter where you are
they're even coming to your families
you know what i'm saying because that's
how he is
that's like he was an older man he was
like um
but certainly by now pimps have a
reputation of course it's similar to
what you're describing
but by me had just getting in the game
and getting to know him
i mean i knew i was you know if it
wasn't right i'ma look for something
yeah but the [ __ ] i seen
i knew i had to get out of it but the
sweet talk you introduced you early on
yes yeah of course that goes with it
yeah yeah but you know
somehow i had to get out of this i
didn't know how when i seen that happen
then when i say
you know take her in the room i'm saying
tricia you got to get out you got to get
out of this
how i don't know i don't know how
but not saying i was glad that he passed
but
that was the only way that was the only
way out and i did i got out
and didn't look back and
sometimes it crossed my mind sometimes
it does
okay so she's going out there and try
again maybe you know
probably see something that's worth it
just like i thought then
then i'll get you know kind of second
thoughts and say no
no don't don't go there you know because
it might be the same and it may not but
then it
you never know because you got crazies
out here you do
you got crazies out here you know you
really do and another time
this man took me to a factory these
factories
and try to rape me luckily
the police was coming to patrol the
factories
i hollered they came
got him and
he had a rap sheet of that of rape and
and whatever and took me to jail but he
was feeling really great
you know he was right for me he was
tearing off my clothes and everything
and luckily i seen the police and i
hollered and they came
sounded like and they got them out and
taken me to jail and they said that's
the one we've been looking for
because he's been raping prostitutes on
figaro
you know but he was you know he was
another clean cut guy nice tie
shirt you know okay hey everything
turned out to be
you know chester molester you know to me
yeah because i was wondering why we're
going in these factories
you know we just turn around go through
right here on the corner or an alley but
you know
it's been it's been an experience you
know
you know my finger my
you know it's just been rough you know
i didn't wake up until now you know
i realized but i be sometimes they cross
the mind sometimes they cross the mind
to where i
go back off their treasure you know
maybe you'll find a nice white man
is that always is that always a dream
for these girls is that maybe you'll
find some friends well
richard gear's going to come by for me
yeah for me yeah
i've heard it before yeah he can he can
you know
he can pimp him but other than that
yeah it's just been it's crazy you know
but
that's just an experience you have to go
through you know when you're having a
life like that
and living a life like that you know so
there's really no why that's why
it's just why you know
but it is what it is but
uh it just was you know an experience
thank you so much for sharing your story
oh you're welcome you're very welcome
i'm glad i did too mm-hmm
you